Prof: All right.
Let's get started.
Here we go again.
Going to have some fun again
today.
Notice, of course,
we have the sign-in sheet when
you come in every morning,
a great thing to do.
As we say, this is not Yale's
most demanding class,
but one thing we do ask you to
do is come to the lectures and
come to section.
You may know if some day you
are in fact ill that you'll get
an e-mail message from me about
a half hour after class is over:
"So sorry to hear that you
were sick this morning.
Hope you're feeling better very
soon."
So we do look after these
things.
Such an e-mail went out last
time, but I'm preaching to the
converted because you're--you
guys are already here so good
for you.
Let's continue with the
discussion of the elements of
music.
We're going to be working today
with harmony.
So far we've had two sessions
specifically on rhythm,
two sessions specifically on
melody, and today we come to
harmony.
Harmony is one of the two
things that really distinguishes
the music of Western
civilization--Western classical
music, Western pop music.
What are the two things?
Well, as mentioned before,
this dependence upon heavy
usage of written musical
notation--
not so much in the pop music
but certainly in the classical
music--
writing it all down,
being able to manipulate it in
that fashion,
so that's one thing that
distinguishes Western classical
music.
Another aspect that we're
talking about today is harmony.
Stop and think about it.
Think about the melodies of
China and Japan,
virtually every--and Islamic
countries--
virtually every musical
civilization around the world
has more sophisticated melodies
than we do in the West.
Ours are very blunt in a way.
They go from one discrete
frequency to another discrete
frequency,
and they're not making use of
all of the material in between
in any sort of nuanced way.
Maybe it's because we're so
dependent on the keyboard here.
So that's important to keep in
mind.
Then let's talk about rhythm
for a moment.
Is Western rhythm particularly
sophisticated?
I was listening as I was coming
in this morning--WMNR.
They had a Strauss waltz
playing there,
>.
How sophisticated is that
rhythmically?
Think of African music where
you have one downbeat and one
pattern working against another
downbeat and another pattern.
Caribbean music--African
influence, the same kind of
thing.
It's worlds ahead in terms of
sophistication with regard to
rhythm.
But the one thing that's
distinguished Western music is
this idea of harmony,
this concept of superimposing
multiple pitches.
Interesting idea that you have
this sound <<plays
piano>>
, then you put another one with
it, >
, then put another one with it,
another one,
>
, something like that,
and you can play with these and
manipulate these in interesting
kinds of ways.
So piling up sounds
simultaneously--
this idea of harmony--is what
makes Western music very
special,
and what we end up with here--I
just reached for anything in my
office--
here is the overture to a score
of a Mozart opera.
And look here,
how many parts we have playing
simultaneously.
Some of them may be repeating
pitch names so somebody may be
playing a C here and somebody
else a C up there,
that sort of thing.
They may be duplicating pitch
names,
but you could have anywhere up
to ten--
well, in this case about
fifteen--different sounds going
at once,
and you don't get that in other
musical cultures.
Let's talk for a moment about
chords.
What's a chord?
Well, a chord is just a
simultaneous sounding of two or
more pitches.
And that's a very basic general
definition of a chord.
And a chord can be,
of course, consonant
>
or it can be <<plays
piano>>
dissonant.
So let's stick with
>
just consonant chords.
We'll be working with consonant
chords today and the most
fundamental of the consonant
chords is this idea of the
triad--
this figure that we call the
triad.
It's the building block,
really, of all our harmonies,
whether it's pop or classical.
And we're going to use a lot of
pop music today and there'll
be--we'll be pointing out triads
there in this pop music.
So what's a triad?
Well, obviously you get the
idea of three pitches.
How does it work?
Let's go over to the keyboard
and the staff here.
Let's say we've got a scale and
we do have a scale,
>
C, D, E, F, G,
A, B, C, and I wanted to
construct a triad above each of
these notes of the scale.
Well, I take-- well,
this happens to be a C,
middle C here,
so a triad is going to have
three pitches.
You--and it spans five letter
names--and we go one letter
name, two letter names,
three letter names,
four letter names,
five letter names.
We take one, three, and five.
Here I'm taking C,
skipping D, taking E,
skipping F and taking G,
and it gives me this three-note
aggregate.
Take one, skip,
take one, skip,
take one, >
and we can do the same thing
>
and so on right up the scale in
that fashion.
Notice, as we've said before,
we've got the scale,
we've got some notes rather
important in the scale.
Tonic is very important,
we've said, the--
>
the leading tone is important
so with chords and triads.
Some are very important.
The tonic is very important and
this dominant--what we call the
dominant.
It's not really the most
important.
It sort of leads into,
pulls into--particularly
important setting up the tonic.
It's the next important.
Right below that is the
sub-dominant.
It often pulls into the
dominant which then pulls into
the tonic in that fashion.
So we would get this idea of
here is a chord here,
>
there is the tonic,
here is the dominant,
>
there's the sub-dominant,
and there's the tonic.
We can flip this just a little
bit.
We can say, "All right.
Here's our tonic up here"
>
and go that way.
Tonic, sub-dominant,
dominant, tonic,
>
that way.
So we could go--come up from
the tonic or go down from the
tonic.
Generally speaking,
composers are more likely to go
down from the tonic and then
come back up to the tonic and
then they aren't likely to go
the other way.
So we've got these three basic
chords that we're going to talk
about.
There are others there that
we've built on the second and
the seventh degree of the scale,
but these are the most
important.
And it's surprising how much
music these three basic chords
can accommodate and all of the
things-- <<plays
piano>>
dominant, tonic,
finally sub-dominant,
tonic, dominant,
tonic.
So a lot of music is made in
that fashion.
One of my favorite pieces,
and I thought it was because
it's a good teaching piece and I
thought it was known just to me
and other old codgers,
is an old cowboy song called
"Streets of Laredo,"
but last night I looked it up
on You--
not on YouTube,
on iTunes, and there are one
hundred thirty-nine recordings
of that that you can buy now--
Johnny Cash,
Arlo Guthrie,
but I'm interested--
>
anybody ever heard that before?
Raise your hand if you've heard
that.
One, two, three--well,
a few people.
So it's a cowboy song.
>
"As I walked out in the
streets of Laredo,
as I walked out in Laredo one
day, I spied a cowpoke who was
dressed in white linens,
dressed in white linens as cold
as the clay."
And as I was singing that all I
was doing underneath was playing
the basic harmony,
the chords, and they consist
just of two chords.
>
As I--dominant,
tonic, dominant,
in that fashion.
Why do chords have--why do we
do that?
Why do we have to change these
chords?
Any ideas?
Why do we--why don't we just
say, >
>
"As I walked out in the
streets of--"
Why do we change chords?
Yeah.
Student: The melody
changes.
Prof: The melody changes
>
and because the melody changes
and you keep banging that same
aggregate against it it's going
to create what?
A dissonance and we don't
want--we don't like dissonances.
If we're going to have
dissonances, we got to control
them.
>
If--unless I change that chord
underneath when I get up here,
>
that's very dissonant.
It doesn't sound very silent
for "Silent Night"
there, so I need to switch to
another chord <<plays
piano>>
and then switch back to the
original.
And so we change chords to make
the harmony consonant or to make
the harmony harmonious.
All right.
So that's something that we
need to keep in mind.
Here's something else
that's--we're going to ask you
to focus on and that is the rate
of harmonic change.
We're really going to be asking
you two things.
Is the harmony changing? Okay?
Can you--is the harmony
changing or is it static?
And if it is changing,
is it changing at a regular or
irregular rate?
By regular rate,
every time a chord sounds it
will be holding for exactly the
same amount of time.
Let's go back to "Streets
of Laredo."
>
Conduct.
--three, one,
two, three
>.
What do you think?
Regular or irregular?
Regular. Okay?
But no--well, okay.
So that's regular.
Let's go on to another one.
>
Okay.
I'm doing a lot there in the
bass to make it more
interesting,
but let's strip that down just
to the fundamental chord that's
underneath of that so we're--
_>.
We're sitting here on the tonic
chord and we'll go
>
, and we could even count it
out: >
>
one-two, two-two,
three-two, four-two,
one-two, one-two,
one-two, two-two,
three-two, four-two,
one-two, one-two.
So some chords there are
holding for--
I guess four measures--four
bars--and some for two and some
for just one,
so that's an irregular rate of
harmonic change.
So we're not going to be asking
you is--
are we--"what chord do we
have here,"
and expect you to say
sub-dominant or "what chord
do we have you,"--
here and expect you to say
dominant.
We're going to be working with
more fundamental things.
Is the harmony changing?
Is it changing at a regular or
irregular rate?
Okay.
Notice I was playing up here
>
a little "Jingle
Bells."
So what is it in music that
sets the harmony?
What part?
Who--what's the foundation of
harmony?
What instrument plays it?
Where in the texture is it--are
we talking high,
low, middle?
Low.
It's the bass.
The bass--it's like these
pillars.
Think of architecture.
You get-your--you put these
pilings in and then you can
build other things around it.
Well, those basic notes:
>
the tonic note,
the dominant note,
the sub-dominant note,
they're sort of the pilings,
and you can ornament around the
piling.
>
That's just--I could
in that fashion.
That would be simple,
from dominant to tonic,
>
or I could make it a little
more interesting.
>
And that's kind of what bass
players do whether they're
playing electric bass in a rock
band--
maybe in an even more
sophisticated way--
an acoustic bass in a symphony
or a double bass in a bluegrass
band.
And who is the world's most
famous double bass player in a
bluegrass band?
Anybody know?
Well, think here at Yale.
Well, we'll see.
Now what we've got here--let--
This is one that this world
famous bass player was kind
enough to loan me.
It was something put together
by Kentucky Public Television so
let's bring up this screen.
So here's the setup.
We've got a DVD from Kentucky
Public Television involving,
as you will see,
some people that may look
familiar.
Does this person look familiar?
Does anybody know this person?
She's a student around here.
She was a Yale undergraduate
and she's telling us how she
tried out for the Yale Symphony
Orchestra, and she was
designated as an alternate.
And she was crestfallen,
but she then saw this ad where
some people wanted her to play
in a bluegrass band.
So let's watch what happens.
>
"--trapped in a classical
violinist's body,
so I guess they were kind of
pessimistic about my playing--
you know, they wanted real
fiddle player,
so she was like 'You're from
West Virginia.
You should go on down there and
audition for that!'
And so luckily,
no other fiddle players showed
up, they were like
>
Mozart?
--So they were very kind to let
me kind of,
you know, get my training on
the job and so I started playing
with them at that point and it's
just been great ever
since."
>
Okay.
So our mystery bass player is
Peter Salovey,
the new provost.
And I sent him an e-mail--I
said, "Peter,
look.
We're teaching bass over here.
Why don't you come in and bring
your bass in and you can
demonstrate this stuff."
"Oh, I'm a little bit busy
>
at the moment but I got this
DVD.
You can have this DVD and do
whatever you want to it."
So what's he doing there?
>
And he's working around these
particular notes in this
particular piece.
We're going to say here is a C,
>
there's the subdominant,
then it goes
>
and oftentimes he's going
>.
But again it's just fleshing
out that subdominant chord,
dominant chord and tonic chord,
and it's--and we can all hear
this.
Do we see--is this guy playing
off the music?
Again, get across the
point--not using music.
How are they doing this?
They're hearing the chords.
They're hearing tonic,
subdominant and dominant,
and I think we can hear them
too.
Anybody out there hearing these
chords?
Can you sing along with these?
This is wonderful music.
It's great.
I--how many like this music?
It's happy music, again.
Is it--we should have a whole
course on bluegrass music.
It could really be good 'cause
a lot of interesting ethnic
issues involved there.
So let's continue here--and
I'll sort of bang on the
piano--sing the basic pitches of
the bass.
And I hope you'll join with me
here.
If you don't like bluegrass,
you don't have to sing but if
you like bluegrass sing along
with me here.
Okay.
Here we go.
>
Now I think this is Craig
Harwood, who actually went
through our Ph.D.
program.
He's the dean of one of the
colleges around here.
What college?
What?
Davenport.
So he's very good--playing the
mandolin here.
He also runs a Klezmer Band.
>
>.
I don't know.
Is this too goofy--or stay with
this >
or ditch this?
I think it's wonderful but you
seem less excited by it than I.
All right.
Let's talk about how these
basses--
we said that the bass note is
sort of the foundation and then
you add these other things up
above it,
and they produce these chords
and the chords are tonic and
dominant and so on.
Sometimes if you're have a solo
instrument the--you can play the
bass as just a chord
>
or you could play it
--the same notes but spinning
them out.
And we call that an
arpeggio--probably 'cause the
harps play this a lot,
a sort of arpeggio,
>
--taking the notes of the triad
and just spinning them out in
succession.
And arpeggios work particularly
well with--on triads with pieces
that happen to be in three.
>
"As I walked out in the
streets of Laredo,"
--one, two, three,
one, two, three.
So that's an arpeggio--just a
chord with the notes played
successively to create an
arpeggio.
It works less well--these
triadic arpeggios--with pieces
in two.
>
That's not so good.
Right?
>
Kind of a metrical train wreck
there.
So what we would do with that
would be to find another
pattern.
And one of the favorite
patterns ever since the
eighteenth century was this
thing called an Alberti bass.
It goes <<plays
piano>>
one, then up to the fifth note,
degree of the triad--one,
five, three,
five, one, five,
three, five.
>
And it sounds very classical.
But that's a good way of
harmonizing something--making
something that's not very
interesting sound more
interesting.
Another way of doing it is just
taking a note,
>
kind of a boogie-woogie
bass--if you just take octaves
and roll it that way.
Beethoven does this in the
sonata <<plays
piano>>
and so on.
So there you can get the
harmony to sound more
interesting simply by rolling
that octave underneath.
So all of these little tricks
sort of energize the music,
and, again, make it more
interesting than it otherwise
perhaps would be.
Sometimes harmonies can stand
by themselves.
Sometimes you could take just
the harmony and it would be very
beautiful.
J.S.***Bach--
J.S. Bach wrote a prelude to
the first book of his
"Well-Tempered
Clavier."
And it's a famous work.
It goes this way <<plays
piano>>
and so on.
All it really is is
>
a succession of chords played
as arpeggios.
So there it sat for
about--well, I would--could say
rather specifically about one
hundred and forty years or so.
And the French composer in the
nineteenth century,
Charles Gounod,
came along and said,
"Well, gee, that's nice,
but I could write a melody
against that."
So we're going to listen to
this--listen to Bach's harmony
underneath.
At the same time we listen to
this lovely melody that Charles
Gounod composed for it.
And it gives a chance to think
about melody and it gives us a
chance to think about the sound
of the cello.
The cello is a particularly
beautiful instrument.
I've always said if I ever come
back as a musical instrument I
want to come back as a cello.
And it's just so rich and so
beautiful and it can soar.
So let's listen to a lovely
cello line added over top of
Bach's original harmony.
>
Descending sequence.
Here the pattern shows up again
but at a lower step.
>
Now it sounds as if he's going
to do it yet a third time,
but this time he takes that
melody and moves up with it.
>
Now the rest of this,
he's arching for a high moment
and we'll get to that.
It's building higher and higher.
>
It comes back to the tonic
after that lovely climax at the
top of that.
So we need to point out that
we've got these two types of
chords here, the idea of the--
>
This was all in C major but we
could turn this into C minor.
Let's go back and review this.
We have up on the board again
the scale.
And we need to talk about these
triads that are made up of
either major or minor thirds.
Here we could look at this way
with this particular interval
and this particular interval.
Let's go over to the keyboard
here 'cause I think it's easier
to show here so we're going to
start here with C because C is
kind of revenue neutral.
We'll start here with C and
we're going to take--skip one,
take one, skip one,
take one, so we do C,
E, G.
Notice coming up here,
we have one,
two, three, four half steps
here.
This is an interval.
This interval from C up to E is
the interval of a third because
it spans three letter names.
C up to G is a fifth.
It spans five letter names.
So we have C,
D, E being a third with one,
two, three, four steps in
it--half steps.
Now we're going to go from E up
to G.
Notice here we get one,
two, three--just three.
And that's because,
as I said before,
we've got this arbitrary
division of the octave according
to Greek mathematics onto which
in the ninth and tenth and
eleventh century the Benedictine
monks laid on another system
that didn't quite work.
So up here this all seems to be
the same distance.
E to F seems to be the same
distance as D to E but it's not.
It's only half the distance.
So we get this funny
disjunction in the keyboard
here.
But in any event,
the important thing to note is
that we have a major triad with
the big third on the bottom and
the little third on the top.
If we switched this around now
and went to C,
E-flat, G to give us the minor
triad,
then, of course,
we would have just three half
steps here and four here.--
or reciprocal angles or
something like that.
You change one--ipso
facto, you change the other.
But that's all of this in play
and we've seen this in play
before.
Just the positioning of that
third will determine whether
this triad is a major triad or a
minor triad.
Let's see how this works out in
terms of real sound.
I'd like for you guys down
here-- >
Just hold that pitch.
>
And TAs, can you sing the fifth?
And nice and loud,
everybody, and everyone else--
>
There is the major third.
Work with me.
Everybody else sing that third.
>
Now we're going to go minor.
Major, minor, major, okay.
And it's just tweaking that
middle note of the triad there.
That's all that's really
involved.
And composers have tweaked this.
Here's a piece by Franz Liszt.
It was re-orchestrated by a
contemporary composer,
called "Lugubrious
Gondola"
in French--
or in English,
translated from the French.
Let's listen to a bit of it.
It starts out with a woodwind
instrument.
What woodwind instrument is
playing here?
And then we'll focus on the
change from one triad to the
next.
>
So what instrument was that?
Did you pick that up?
Now everybody--yeah,
it was a clarinet.
Now if we were doing this on a
quiz or a test,
we'd probably play that three
times so that you'd hear it a
lot more than just that,
but it was a clarinet.
Now we go to this sound
>
and watch what happens.
Moves to another chord,
>
--minor, major,
minor, major,
minor.
Let's pause it there and reset
that just a little bit,
because underneath,
what's the bass doing here?
>
What's that?
Arpeggio.
Yeah, just an arpeggio
underneath.
So sometimes we take these
chords and we'll just use it as
an arpeggio to support.
>
Remember last time?
That's all Puccini does-- by
way of a harmonic support there,
just takes that tonic chord and
>
basically just works that out
as an arpeggio underneath.
All right.
So let's see how--if we can
begin to hear the distinction
between a major triad and a
minor triad,
and for this we're going to
turn to a very famous piece--
the "Moonlight
Sonata" of Beethoven,
and I ask you--if you got a
piece of paper there--
I hope you do--we're going to
play nineteen chords for you and
we're going to ask you which is
major and which is minor.
So, you know the piece.
>
So I'm going to sort of strip
these down to their essence
here.
Here's chord number one:
major triad or minor triad?
>
Here's chord number two.
Here's three,
>
four, <<plays
piano>>
five.
>
Here's six, <<plays
piano>>
seven.
>
Here comes eight.
Here's nine,
>
ten, >
eleven.
>
Here's twelve,
thirteen, <<plays
piano>>
fourteen, <<plays
fifteen, <<plays
piano>>
sixteen, <<plays
seventeen.
>
Here's eighteen <<plays
piano>>
and nineteen <<plays
piano>>.
That's nineteen.
>
So how did you do?
Well, let's see here.
Let's go back and double check
this.
>
Now that's a minor chord.
I'll just tell you the answers
here.
>
That's major.
This is minor.
>
Three is minor.
Four is minor.
>
What about that one?
That may be a tough one.
>
Is that a major chord or a
minor chord?
Major.
>
Some of these are hard,
though.
>
Major or minor?
Major.
>
Okay. That was six.
Here's seven.
>
Excuse me.
Seven is <<plays
piano>>
major.
Eight is <<plays
piano>>
minor.
Nine is <<plays
piano>>
major.
Ten is major.
>
Eleven is <<plays
piano>>
minor.
Twelve is major.
>
Thirteen is <<plays
piano>>
minor.
Fourteen, minor.
>
Fifteen, minor.
Sixteen, minor.
>
Seventeen, <<plays
piano>>
major.
Eighteen, <<plays
piano>>
minor.
Nineteen, <<plays
piano>>
major.
So we'll be working--this I
think is fair game,
just to differentiate between a
major triad and a minor triad.
And we'll be doing that on the
test a week from now but we'll
be giving you lots of prepping
in that in section this week.
Let's return to the pop realm
and focus continually here on
harmony and combine the idea of
harmony with major and minor
triad.
I'm going to play a piece that
I've always liked by U2.
I don't really know much about
them but it's an interesting
piece, "Love is
Blindness."
Let's listen to chunks of this
and we'll see what they're doing
with the harmony here.
>
What's the meter?
Kind of a slow what?
Okay.
So for copyright reasons we're
cutting this exactly short.
We don't want to go over our
limit here.
Okay.
So we're going to skip ahead
now and listen to just a little
bit more.
>
I think that's kind of the beat
here, kind of a slow beat.
Let's hear just a little bit
more and then I'll start to play
along, and I want you to count
the number of bars--number of
measures--in the pattern.
This is a pattern that repeats
over and over.
In music when that pattern
repeats, we call it an
ostinato--ostinare,
from the Italian word
ostinare:
stubborn, pigheaded.
So we have an ostinato harmony
here and how many bars is in
this ostinato--are there in this
ostinato pattern?
>
One, two, two-- <<music
playing>>
Anybody able to count the
number of bars in the pattern
just on that one little quick
playing there?
Yeah, Betty.
Student: Sixteen.
Prof: Sixteen?
Okay.
You're on the right track.
Roger?
Eight, yeah.
It was a sixteen-bar pattern.
It was a--we played sixteen
bars there, but the harmony of
the second eight bars was
identical to the harmony of the
first eight bars.
It was just repeating that same
harmony.
What's the harmony?
>
Is this piece by U2 in major or
minor?
Everybody who think major
>
raise your right hand.
Sinister minor types,
raise your left hand.
>
It's definitely a minor so it's
one of these unusual pop pieces
in minor.
All right.
So that's chord one.
That's the tonic.
What about this triad?
Major or minor?
>
Major.
What about this one?
>
Major.
What about this one?
>
Minor.
Okay.
Then back to <<plays
piano>>
minor, <<plays
major, <<plays
piano>>
and minor at the end.
So that's our eight-bar pattern.
Now maybe even kind of sing
along with this.
My question to you,
and this is the last one with
this piece,
is: is this an example of a
regular rate of harmonic change
or an irregular rate of harmonic
change?
So here we go.
Maybe I'll just play it on the
piano--just the simplest thing
here.
Ready, go.
>
So what do you think?
Regular or irregular?
How many think regular?
How many think irregular?
It's actually irregular.
Thaddeus, tell me why.
Anybody tell me why?
I just like to put you on the
spot here but you got it right.
Student: Well,
>
.
Prof: Well,
no.
They were kind of falling
on--they were falling on the
meter, okay, but there was one
moment when something was a
little bit different.
Elizabeth?
Student: It didn't--it
lasted longer.
Prof: Okay.
It lasted longer.
What's the "it" here?
Student: The chord lasts
longer at the end of the phrase.
Prof: Okay.
At the end of the phrase,
>
seven--no, six--seven-two,
eight-two, so that one lasted
two bars: <<plays
piano>>
one-two, two-two,
three-two, four-two,
five-two, six-two,
seven-two, eight-two.
So one of those chords lasted,
actually--one of those chords
toward the end there lasted
twice as long as all the others.
Roger, a question?
Student:
>
Prof: It could
conceivably be a rest but that
would give us kind of a
seven-bar phrase and I don't
like seven-bar phrases.
I've never met a seven-bar
phrase that I was really
comfortable with.
And musicians generally don't
like that so it's better to go
with--
I've used this for the first
time in section the other day
and I'll use it again here a
second time.
Occam's razor:
if there's a simple solution,
go for it.
And so take the idea of
symmetry and assume that it's an
eight-bar phrase and you've got
one chord holding for an extra
chord,
but theoretically that's
possible.
A question here?
Student:
>
Prof: We would not get
in to that but it would still be
considered regular.
All they're doing is filling
between chord--like Peter
Salovey.
>
Okay.
All here's doing is
>
and if he comes-- <<plays
piano>>
playing other things along the
way that's still regular.
But that's far more
sophisticated than we're ever
going to get to.
We're just going to go
"plunk, plunk,
plunk."
Okay?
So keep it very much in the
straight and narrow.
All right.
We have one more idea to talk
about and that is the concept of
key and modulation.
Now this piece by U2
>
is written in a key.
It's got the home key here.
It's an odd key.
It's B-flat minor: five flats.
B flat minor.
But it nonetheless is a key and
the whole piece--at least the
vast majority of it,--is in that
one key.
Occasionally,
composers will change keys.
I was thinking I could play for
you here the Beethoven.
He starts-- <<plays
piano>>
So here we are in this minor
key >
and here he is in a new key.
This is <<plays
piano>>
a major key here.
So composers do change keys.
And when they change keys they
effect what's called a
modulation.
Let's listen to an example of--
Let's listen to an example of a
pretty simple modulation
effected by Aaron Copland,
an American composer working in
New York City in the forties,
fifties, sixties and
seventies--wrote a ballet suite
called "Appalachian
Spring."
And in it he has one section
where he's working through a
series of variations on a folk
tune called "A Gift to be
Simple" and he pulls off a
modulation.
So let's listen to Copland's
"Appalachian Spring"
as he proceeds,
and I'll kind of try to
duplicate and go crazy up here
at the piano at the moment we
get to the modulation.
Modulations are hard to hear.
The best you can do is that
oftentimes is say,
"This is unsettled.
Maybe it's modulating,"
and we--I don't--I'm not even
sure we would ask you,
"Has the piece
modulated?"
They're really kind of hard to
hear.
But let's try anyway.
So here's a Copland modulation.
>
So here he is in this key.
I think this is where the
modulation comes.
Then he's going to bring in
the-- <<plays
piano>>
He's sitting on this note.
He brings in the trombones
>
and then the trumpet will jump
off from there <<plays
piano>>
to a much higher--he was here
>
and now he's modulated up to
here.
>
So let's see if we can hear
this modulation now.
>
Here we go.
So that's a modulation.
In music--conceptually it's
pretty straightforward but it's
hard to hear.
I think I've got an--one that's
easier to hear.
It's a piece I like to use
because it's just off the charts
in terms of what other popular
music was doing at that time.
It's a piece by the Beach Boys.
Beach Boys music is extremely
interesting--you might think,
"these California
airheads."
No, no, no, no.
This is really musically just
light years ahead of what
everybody else was doing,
I guess late fifties,
early sixties.
So what I've got here on the
board is a harmonic scheme and
we're going to once again for
copyright reasons just take
little chunks of this.
But you can see that it's a
piece that changes--uses--a lot
of triads.
So every time you see a G up
here that means we have a chord
built on G and a triad on E,
triad on A, triad on F,
D, E.
And just looking at this,
this isn't shaping out to be
one, four, five,
one, so it's moving around a
lot.
Then it gets to a section where
it does get very boring.
It's very static at that
particular point.
And then something of interest
will happen.
So let's listen to a little bit
of this and there are--
it's a piece in which there are
contrasts between sections of
movement with wild modulations
and then sections of stases.
>
Okay.
So here it gets very boring and
we're not going to even listen
to it.
It's just going to sit there,
>,
"I'm really hip and I'm
having a great time,"
but then the text comes back to
"I get around."
So let's--I think that's
what--I've had to parse this
thing out into a Frankenstein,
but let's listen to the next
thing.
I think we go back to the idea
of "I get around."
>
More boring stuff at this point
but let's pick it up as we come
to the end of what I think is
this boring stuff and we'll
listen to what they do there.
>
>.
So they're sitting here in
which they're
>
>.
So what kind of cadence have
they give us there?
Deceptive cadence.
Deceptive cadence and that
>
takes us up the half step and
then it jumps-- <<plays
piano>>.
No.
It doesn't jump to the Aaron
Copland "Appalachian
Spring" but it does the
same thing.
It does exactly the same thing.
It uses that
>.
It's going to jump up from the
dominant to the tonic and then
slide up one more step--
so that now we have now a whole
section in A-flat and the
original was in G.
So he's modulated to A-flat.
And it's extremely
sophisticated,
involving half step modulations
and things like that.
Who would have 'thunk' that
from the Beach Boys?
All right.
We're going to stop here.
We've got sections this week.
We have a test a week from
today.
If you look at your e-mails
later in the day,
you'll see an e-mail from me
saying that we are posting a
prep sheet for the test and it
will tell you all you need to
know and how to study over the
weekend for the test next
Thursday.
So let's listen to a little bit
of the Aaron Copland as you go
out.